(upbeat music)
I love helping people with design.
And so I'm excited that we recently got
to do a little home reno right here
in our wardrobe department.
We are going to get a washer dryer and over there...
A styler.
And that's the steamer...
That's the steamer unit.
Yeah.
That feels like having a dry cleaner.
I think we paint every single thing we can.
Yeah.
Let me think.
I think I know so emphatically what I like.
I still like this one.
Me too!
Okay, great.
It was a clothes call, (laughs)
but everyone got to work quick,
and I'm so excited that we teamed up with LG
for this design by Drew.
We've installed the LG wash tower
with these center controls.
It's the first of its kind.
And it gives you room to do so much more with your space.
The wash tower is the perfect touch to make our little haven
chic yet modern.
I really can't believe that we are fortunate enough
to work with professional grade machinery like this
in our wardrobe closet.
It's a dream come true.
And I love LG, and these are stunning.
Can you believe how that unfolded?
Yep, I did it again.
I hope you had loads of fun like I did.
Mm-hmm, okay, all right, I'll stop.
(upbeat music)